here with reaction Lieutenant Colonel
Oliver North is was with us Colonel you
know what you fought in Vietnam you were
in Afghanistan you in Iraq you you you
are proud of the fact that you have
spent your life with Heroes you are one
of them in my lifetime I can't think of
a time that it's been this dangerous and
I'm including the Cold War here and my
dad spent four years in the Pacific the
the threat of I think real world chaos
and a possible world war is more I think
that's more possible than at any point
in my lifetime Am I
Wrong No in fact what we just heard from
the vice president a few moment ago the
strategy is don't don't is not a
strategy you know you and I were
together last week and we offered advice
on how the Biden Administration could
deter Iran from starting a multi-front
war on our Ally Israel as yet none of
that's been done and so tonight a little
bit more free advice for for the obid
Biden Administration how to solve the
problem of freeing more than 230
American Israeli French German Italian
Egyptian and other nationality held
hostage by Hamas and Islamic Jihad in
Gaza Mr Biden ought to go on national TV
and announced he has conferred with
Israeli Prime Minister Netanyahu and
ordered the immediate deployment of a
thousand bed hospital ship usns comfort
from Northfolk Virginia to station it 13
miles off the coast of Gaza adjacent to
the the Rafa Crossing which is the only
place people can get in and out of of of
Gaza as long as president alisi allows
them to right now it's still closed look
it's just north of the border crossing
in the in the sun in the cyanide Egypt
ESET Al
Sagal is is a place where you could
station that vessel off that Shore the
usns Comfort will be available to treat
Palestinian women and children in need
of medical care and Mr Biden needs to
call President Al Abdul Alat Al
alisi and invite him to allow the 26
Marine Expeditionary Unit to utilize the
port at ESET Abu shakal and the Alish
International Airport in Sinai that we
have used for to support them the
international United Nations uh
monitoring operation out there and
establish a triage there for processing
the transporting of the sick and injured
and infirm Palestinian women and
children out to the usns Comfort for
medical treatment our Navy and Marines
have the hilos the MV 22s and the
experience of ship toore vessels and
movement necessary for this task he
should also direct Secretary of State
blinkin to notify representatives of the
government of qar to inform Hamas that
with with whom that they are in direct
contact we expect that for every five
Palestinian women and children treated
aboard the hospital ship at least one
hostage will be released each time there
are of course many details to be worked
out on this kind of humanitarian Mission
the sea Transit from norol to Gaza is
about 5,500 mil at 20 knots the hospital
ship could be on station in less than 14
days by then details can be ironed out
so that this life-saving endeavor can
get underway I can almost assure you
that there's nobody who wants to do such
a thing in this Administration but they
should and we ought to assure prime
minister netan this is not being done to
stop the IDF from continuing their
Counterattack on a m terrorist who
murdered, 1400 Israelis on October 7th
I'll CCE must be convinced to invite the
US Marine Corps US Navy Mission toore in
the Sinai Coast
we ought to assure leaders of Israel and
Egypt that we will provide accurate
identity information to the
International Red Cross and the red
crescent for every Palestinian flowing
out to the hospital ship now what's
going to happen to the Palestinian
civilians after their medical treatment
that can be worked out it's the kind of
thing that people ought ought to want to
do the positive information management
of this humanitarian effort should help
prove to those instigating those promas
protests you just add on the screen on a
college campus
around the world that America Israel and
Egypt can act to protect innocent human
life in the midst of War go ahead I want
to save them but I'll add one thing
Colonel your idea is a great idea um
they want lights back on they want
selfservice uh they want any sort of
humanitarian assistance at all which I'm
skeptical of they got to release every
hostage that's it otherwise Israel must
defend its Homeland Colonel we
appreciate you more than you know thank
you sir I said Israel's got to continue
to do that God bless you cify simpy my
friend hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else